you look at the research the majority of
books that have been banned fall into
two camps either they have characters of
color or talk about race in some way or
they have characters that are of the
lgbtq community or touch upon those
themes in some way and I have to think
about what messaging that sense to young
readers it's as if you're saying you are
inappropriate if you're African-American
you are inappropriate if you are gay you
are inappropriate if you are an
immigrant and there's this huge argument
that it's about protecting and
Sheltering our children from themes that
are just too advanced from them but when
you look at the majority of the books
that have actually been banned it's more
about creating a bookshelf that doesn't
represent the diverse facets of America